[Música]
quiénes son las personas que más amas en
esta vida cuáles son tus momentos
favoritos
cuáles son las cosas que te hacen sentir
feliz
vamos a imaginar y reflexionar un poco
para mí es cuando llego de trabajo y
escucho a mi hijo gritar papito papito
brinca hacia mí nos fundimos en un
fuerte y calentito abrazo
para mí es tener un lugar cálido donde
vivir para mí es trabajar en un lugar
que tanto me apasiona y lo que tanto me
gusta hacer dando clases y para ti qué
es lo que te hace ser feliz
tal vez probar esa comida de tu abuelita
tal vez ponerte esa camisa que te hace
sentir también ir a bailar con tus
amigos
manejar tu coche hacia lugares
desconocidos mientras disfrutas del
atardecer y la naturaleza
cocinar pasar tiempo con tu familia ver
la televisión en este lugar favorito de
esto sillón
disfrutar de poco tu pareja o tal vez
disfrutar de tu soledad mientras lees tu
libro favorito o escuchas aquella buena
música creo que se siente muy bien
recordar todas aquellas cosas que nos
hacen sentirse felices ahora vamos a
hacer un ejercicio imaginemos que todo
esto un día desaparece en un instante y
de la nada ya no está tu hijo para
correr hacia ti ya no tienes un trabajo
no tienes una casa un techo tu familia
tu pareja y tu salud
se siente muy difícil pensar en este
momento
porque todo esto vive en un solo
recuerdo
este sentimiento que se podemos sentir
de angustia y desesperación y
frustración fue el mismo sentimiento que
despertó en mí un sentimiento tan fuerte
de empatía mismo que despertó en
millones de mexicanos y que nos hizo
dejar atrás todos aquellos objetivos que
por mucho tiempo nos adjudicamos dejamos
atrás un méxico del que transa no avanza
un méxico corrupto flojo dejado cangrejo
y borramos por un instante ante el mundo
un méxico un mexicano sentado bajo un
nopal
y nos convertimos en un méxico con cappa
en mexico que se vistió de héroe y que
demostró que por segunda ocasión podemos
luchar y enfrentarnos ante todas las
adversidades para renacer entre los
escombros con valor
12 millones de sacrificados 400
municipios afectados 378 vidas y 38
edificios derrumbados creo y ya saben de
lo que estoy hablando estoy hablando del
19 de septiembre día del renacimiento de
méxico día donde un país entero relación
entre la madre tierra y de un parto
natural para convertirnos en un nuevo y
mejor país
mi nombre es oscar peinado soy maestro
soy padre de familia y vengo aquí a
relatar la historia de un 19 19 de
septiembre que para para que para mí es
el día y la lección más importante de mi
vida
eran las 5 de la tarde
llegué de mi trabajo y como siempre pero
mi hijo muy feliz a gritar papito
nostrum entre mis brazos y le dio un
fuerte peso en este momento
la mamá de mi hijo me dice óscar ya
viste las noticias
lo que pasó volteo veo el televisor y
veo una imagen que se creó bajo que se
quedó grabada en mi vida para siempre
esa imagen es la de dos valientes
ciudadanos que arriesgaron sus vidas y
tomaron entre sus manos unos muros los
levantaron se adentraron entre los
escombros y tomaron a dos pequeños niños
de entre 4 y 5 años para rescatarlos
mientras este niño era rescatado gritaba
mamá mamá extraño a mi mamá en ese
momento sentado contra mi hijo del agua
tomé una decisión de la que no me voy a
arrepentir jamás
decisión que estoy seguro que ustedes
también hubieran tomado si hubieran
estado en indigna situación
este día 19 de septiembre comenzaron mis
vacaciones estaba a punto de disfrutar
las primeras vacaciones con mi hijo así
que tenía una semana disponible tenía un
vuelo para cancún con escala en la
ciudad de mexico
otro factor importante que afectó es que
en esta ciudad en la ciudad de méxico
estaba mi madre
así que tome esta decisión y la ciudad
de mexico
sabía que tenía que hacer algo no sabía
que quería hacer una pequeña diferencia
por más mínimo que fuera
lo primero que pensé fue
voy a llevar equipo y herramientas para
estos rescatistas estos rescatistas que
estaban tomando esos muros con sus manos
desprotegidas llevaré amantes llevaré
rodilleras y coderas y linternas ellos
lo necesitan
publique mis redes sociales tengo un
vuelo a la ciudad de mexico llevaré
cosas para rescatistas si alguien quiere
apoyar estaré a tal hora en el
aeropuerto
para mi sorpresa dos horas antes de
partir llegaron conocidos y desconocidos
a llevar
todo tipo de herramientas solamente
estaba limitado a 45 kilos de equipaje
los votantes pueden encontrar en la
ciudad de méxico a lo cual llegó un
primo
me acompañó y nos dirigimos al centro de
rescate y urgencias médicas de la ciudad
de mexico
el presente con el oficial le dije tengo
el nombre de ciudad juárez a entregar
este equipo que estoy seguro ustedes van
a necesitar
muchas gracias estamos muy agradecidos
con el apoyo de ustedes
también quiero ofrecerme como voluntario
cualquier cosa que ustedes necesiten por
más mínimo que sea quiero apoyar
te lo agradecemos sin embargo allá
afuera hay miles de voluntarios
rescatistas esperando una oportunidad
ahorita no sobran manos
existe cualquier actividad formal mínimo
que sea creo que puede ayudar
en este momento me percaté que el cuarto
la bodega donde tanto las herramientas
que recibiendo látigos se lo metían y
estaban en completo desorden me ofrecí
qué te parece si mi primo y yo
comenzamos a organizar todo el equipo y
herramienta para cuando los rescatistas
lleguen ellos estén listos para ir al
área de rescate
muchas gracias de oficial te agradecemos
y te tomo la palabra
empezamos primero con los más grandes
carl muchas picos palas y barretas
separadas por tamaños y por tipos
posteriormente continuamos con lo
pequeño
rodilleras guantes respiradores
linternas lentes y cascos
todo perfectamente acomodado los tomó
tres horas realizar un proyecto de cinco
meses en esta área
como la frase dice un lugar para cada
cosa y cada cosa en su lugar
pasaron tres horas se acercó al oficial
y nos dijo estamos muy agradecidos por
su apoyo
han demostrado que tienen la actitud de
servicio así que queremos invitarlos a
unirse al cuerpo de rescate que entrará
en acción en las próximas horas para
poder
reemplazar a aquellos que llevan más de
24 horas al servicio
adelante me pregunto tienes alguna
experiencia en una situación similar
[Música]
sí
fin víctimas del terremoto hace 10 años
en lima perú en el 2007 2007
8.1 grados en escala viste muy bien creo
que sabes a lo que te vas a enfrentar
tomen todo el equipo y herramienta
necesaria ustedes ya saben dónde están y
prepárense porque en 5 minutos van a
salir a la siguiente misión me presento
con la capitana y con el resto del
equipo me subí a la unidad en ese
momento yo no sabía lo que me enfrentaba
seguimos llegamos lo primero que veo son
cientos de gentes carpas y personas
acercándose a nosotros ofreciéndonos
café agua tamales tortas lo que fuera se
acercaba también no se aplaudían como si
fuéramos héroes
en este momento yo no sabía lo que
estaba sucediendo ni a lo que estaba a
punto de enfrentar
llegamos en frente estaba una muralla
del ejército nuestra capitana se acerca
se presentan
y dice puede identificarse tenía
nuestros nombres y no tienen acceso
en la otra parte llegamos había
ambulancias miembros de la sedena
militares y víctimas de los familiares
devastados
por favor decía ayúdenos rescaten a
nuestro hijo
la primera imagen que veo
es un edificio de siete pisos de más de
20 metros que ahora quedó disminuido a
tres estoy hablando del edificio de la
álvaro obregón número 286
póngase el equipo llega a un soldado pre
naturista litros de internas entramos
por un edificio de al lado estaba
totalmente oscuro destruido empezamos a
subir por escaleras
aparentemente era una mayoría
brincamos llegamos al tope y desde allí
tomamos una escalera de aluminio para
bajar a lo que era la cima del edificio
álvaro obregón 283 286 donde se
encontraban más de 80 personas
sepultadas
en ese momento todavía no sabía lo que
me enfrentaba
seguía caminando entre los escombros
siguiendo mi equipo el líder se presenta
con el escuadrón que está ahorita en
rescate y pregunta cuál es la situación
señalan a una excavación y dice de aquí
acabamos de rescatar tres personas lucía
es una de ellas
ahora estamos empezando la siguiente
excavación donde 5 metros adelante se
encuentra una sala de juntas y creemos
que existen personas aún con vida
muy bien
el líder empieza a delegar actividades
yo aún no sabía lo que estaba a punto de
pasar
en este momento y primera actividad era
pasar un balde hacia una es que aquí
está que estaba adentro quien se
encargaba de seguir la excavación y
sacar escombros
posteriormente
treinta minutos después realizan un
cambio ahora es mi turno de al usar
tomaba la lámpara ya lo usaba el área
para que la persona que estaba al
rescate pudiera continuar con su labor
en ese momento me sentía todavía
tranquilo
[Música]
posteriormente empiezo a tener una
alarma y todos salen despavoridos hacia
un lugar seguro
una réplica estábamos en el séptimo piso
en una en una losa que estaba a punto de
desplomarse no les miento sentí que casi
moría
pasaron 20 minutos regresamos al área de
rescate
y continuamos nuestra labor
el líder me dice es tu turno colócate el
arnés
en este momento
fue un momento muy difícil sin embargo
la adrenalina y el valor renació de la
parte más profunda de mi toma de dármelo
con lo que me colocaron líneas de vida y
sin ningún
tipo de un experto solamente sigue las
instrucciones que militen me indicaba es
tu turno de romper la quinta rosa
me pasaron el martillo neumático empecé
a destruir un cuarto de las de esta área
levantamos pasan baldes comienzo acá
y comienza a poner escombros y levantan
otra vez
de nuevo hasta neumático otras áreas
comienza a excavar pasan de nuevo el
balde escombro levanto
ahora es el turno del mar para aquellas
áreas que son difíciles estamos con el
mar
terminaron 30 minutos y terminé el
trabajo de la quinta losa de destruir la
quinta losa
salvo continuó con otras actividades
ahora mi turno de ser yo quien pase las
herramientas al siguiente rescatista
en este momento en vez de entender lo
que pasaba
[Música]
el líder no puede actuar con ninguna
actividad única responsabilidad es
delegar actividades y velar con la
seguridad en cada uno de nosotros los
demás estábamos en una rotación
precisamente para estar guardar la
seguridad y la eficiencia de cada uno de
nosotros porque es imposible estar más
de 30 minutos dentro de esa excavación
pasaron más de cuatro horas cuatro de la
mañana es hora de descansar
llegamos a un área
nos prestaron cobijas y antes de dormir
veo mi teléfono y escuchó el mensaje
papito eres mi héroe
me quebré en llanto en ese momento
sin embargo sabía que no podía defraudar
8 de la mañana continuamos los labores
de rescate ahora cambia algo ahora este
momento de los nuevos héroes
héroes que cruzaron un continente para
llegar con el equipo de más alta
tecnología el escalón de rescate del
país de israel
trabajamos y colaboramos con ellos por
cuatro horas tiempo de regresar al
centro de rescate tiempo de
entrenamiento donde fuimos entrenados
por los medios más expertos rescatistas
precisamente a las casitas del terremoto
del 85 donde nos enseñaron técnicas de
apuntalamiento nos dieron asesoría
psicológica y nos dieron servicio médico
empezaron a checar nuestras presiones
alguna lesión si alguno de nosotros se
sentía mal era el relegado de la misión
siguiente misión apuntalamiento colegio
re examen
regresamos nuevamente
descansamos cuatro horas comemos
siguiente misión
vámonos al edificio después la 282
donde en este edificio se encontraban
todavía dos cuerpos con pocas esperanzas
de vida sin embargo en este edificio aún
existía cuarenta seres vivos
a lo que mi líder me dice
oscar tu siguiente misión es rescatar a
40 conejos que se encuentran sepultados
en sus jaulas
esa fue la una de las misiones también
que me tocó vivir cuando me preguntan
las cartas de algún vivo yo siempre no
puedo mentir y digo sí cuántos 40 40
animalitos
la verdad yo solo soy un maestro soy un
ciudadano común y corriente con la mejor
disposición de ayudar no tenía ningún
tipo de experiencia solamente me dediqué
a seguir órdenes si me decían tú me este
mundo ese muro tomaba un marro y lo
derrotaba si me decía quiebres a los ha
tomado el martillo y la quebraba si
mensajes y me decían alumbra levanta
escombro cualquier actividad ellos
indicaban yo lo realizaba al pie de la
letra
esta es la historia de un 19 de
septiembre y sus más de 72 horas
solamente teníamos 72 horas 72 horas
para hacer la diferencia entre la vida y
la muerte 72 horas donde rescató tres
valores de los mexicanos que hicieron un
impacto positivo para lograr renacer
como país
el primero de las lecciones y el primer
valor es el valor de la solidaridad
que se define como el sentimiento de
unidad basado en metas e intereses
comunes sentimiento que quedó al
descubierto cuando millones de mexicanos
sin necesidad de motivarlos a
persuadirlos
hicieron lo que tienen que hacer casi
por inercia hicieron cadenas humanas
cadenas humanas que empezaron desde la
cajuela de un automóvil lleno de víveres
y aguas y que terminaron 1800 kilómetros
después en las manos de una persona que
lo perdió todo cadenas humanas de
mujeres adultos mayores jóvenes y
adultos que durante ciertas horas se
pusieron sus capas de héroes y
levantaron escombros sin ningún tipo de
protección personal
solidaridad los que demostraron los
gobiernos los otros países los tojos los
bomberos el escuadrón de urgencias
médicas de la ciudad de méxico cuando
hicieron actividades perfectamente
coordinadas dignas de aplaudir por
cualquier país para el rescate de estas
personas
el segundo valor que quiero destacar es
el valor de la honestidad el valor de la
honestidad que no es más que la verdad
la justicia y la integridad moral la
integridad moral
para proteger y respetar aquellos bienes
de los damnificados integridad moral
para que aquellas calles de la ciudad de
mexico no tuvieron que ser patrulladas
para hacer justas ya que juntos policías
y ciudadanos estaban al servicio del
rescate
y de nuestro país en tercer valor que
quiero destacar este el valor de la
valentía
esa fuerza interior que nos hace hacer
actividades de heroicas donde el peligro
y el miedo están presentes valentía que
demostraron los ciudadanos que se
adentraron entre los escombros
arriesgaron sus videos para rescatar a
niños niños del colegio del examen
valentía que demostraron los rescatistas
que alegaron sus vidas en edificios que
estaban a punto de caer
valentía los que demostraron aquellas
personas que se integraron a un
laboratorio químico expuestos a posibles
explosiones fugas de gases y derrumbes
por rescatar aunque sea uno de aquellos
15 personas que estaban sepultadas
no les voy a decir la verdad siempre
tuve mucho miedo mucho miedo más sin
embargo siempre estuve acompañado de
personas calificadas entrenadas y
verdaderos héroes que me daban valor
héroes que tienen nombre apodos y
apellidos
gervacio lazio fish el pico de la ruda
por mencionar algunos verdaderos héroes
verdaderos héroes que utilizaron sus
manos como bisturí
y utilizaron la mayor destreza de un
cirujano para realizar la mayor valiente
de las operaciones el rescate de
personas vivas héroes que hoy en este
momento quiero borrar de esta manera y
con un fuerte aplauso
[Aplausos]